wenn man mit menschen wie russland habe
die noch sprechen will muss man glück
haben
menschen wie er sitzen zurzeit häufig in
haft wie die noch gehört zum team von
alexei navalny er zeigt uns die zentrale
der organisation in moskau
hier sehen sie die führungsriege der
putin partei einiges russland wolodin
iwf all die leute die an der spitze
stehen was sich anfühlt wie ein
agententhriller ist einer in diesem
improvisierten büro schlägt das herz der
antikorruptions bewegung immer wieder
kommt die polizei vorbei konfisziert
akten und computer
das hier ist alex sales büro hier machen
wir oft keine sitzungen und
brainstormings es steht leer immer wenn
er festgenommen wird
sonst ist er immer hier allerdings wird
er oft festgenommen eigentlich vor jeder
kundgebung
alexej nawalny russlands unruhestifter
nummer eins an der wand in seinem büro
die youtube play buttons auszeichnungen
für eine millionen reichweite im
internet wie bei seinem jüngsten video
sei hier ist navalny sein letzter coup
war geplant
der film veröffentlicht kurz nach seiner
verhaftung in moskau
navalny erzählt die geschichte vom
geldgierigen staatschef der sich einen
palast bauen lässt finanziert aus
dubiosen geldquellen und der im luxus
schwelgt wie ein russischer louis
kartons stellen sie sich monate vor
es ist klein aber ein souveräner staat
der palast ist 39 mal so groß
goldene toiletten bürsten weingüter heli
landeplätze putin hat all das persönlich
dementiert allein das ist bemerkenswert
nichts von dem was hier als mein besitz
aufgeführt wird gehört mir oder meinen
engen verwandten der stachel aber sitzt
tief navalny es botschaft kommt an mehr
als 90 millionen haben das video schon
gesehen wir sind das effektivste team im
ganzen land wir fordern dieses regime
heraus wir zeigen die korruption
das ganze ausmaß was treibt ihn an
alexej nawalny mut märtyrertum
politisches kalkül den nerven
giftanschlag hat er überlebt jetzt droht
ihm eine lange haftstrafe
er kam trotzdem zurück nach russland
oder genau deshalb
dies ist eine politische geste die
gleichzeitig provozieren so eine offene
herausforderung für das hat gut
funktioniert
navalny hat ausgeholt und mit seiner
rückkehr und dem palast film
zugeschlagen der frontalangriff ist der
film
kurz vor der demo am samstag liegen sich
anastasia und olga in den haaren
so etwas hat in diesem land noch nie
sinn gehabt ihr werdet nur ausgenutzt
von leuten die so etwas brauchen
ich stimme dir zu aber wie lange kann
man denn zu hause sitzen bleiben nun du
wirst bald im knast sitzen ein konflikt
zwischen mutter und tochter zur demo
gehen oder nicht
navalny hatte zu protesten aufgerufen
nicht genehmigten protesten für menschen
wie anastasia und ihre freunde ist eine
teilnahme gefährlich sie haben viel zu
verlieren
anastasia ist maklerin und
konzertveranstalterin sie geht zum
ersten mal in ihrem leben auf eine
demonstration
ja ich habe angst auch um die kinder
hier aber wir müssen heute hier sein
sie sind nicht nur wegen einer weile
hier sie fordern seine freilassung es
geht ihnen aber auch um russlands
zustand um korruption zensur die
angeschlagene wirtschaft alexej nawalny
ist für viele der auslöser einige sagen
jetzt ich bin nicht hier wegen der
wahlen sondern wegen etwas bedeutenderen
aber hierher hat uns heute doch navalny
gebracht die wurzeln dieser demo heute
gehen zurück auf den tag im august als
wir erfuhren dass er vergiftet wurde aus
der haft heraus haben navalny und sein
team menschen auf die straße gebracht so
viele waren seit jahren nicht mehr auf
dem muss dabei nis pr-abteilung
verbindet sein schicksal mit den
missständen des landes und dem angriff
auf putin
das scheint zu funktionieren vor allem
im netz
auf tik tok explodiert der hashtag
navalny junge menschen hängen putin
bilder abmachen navalny zum social media
star russlands behörden fordern das
verbot solcher post sie verbreiten sich
dennoch millionenfach in vielen städten
und elf zeitzonen von caparros bis sankt
petersburg rufen am samstag zehntausende
putin ist ein dieb ich glaube dass die
korruption aus der politik verschwinden
ich will dass wir russen in würde leben
können
besonders nach diesen videos auf youtube
und nachdem unsere gehälter jetzt in
klobürsten bemessen werden der staat
lässt sie nicht gewähren reagiert mit
harter hand
rund 3500 menschen werden verhaftet
das kann sich zu einem schneeballeffekt
entwickeln wenn das regime mit
exzessiver gewalt auf die proteste
reagiert
dann kann es sein dass außenstehende
unbeteiligte menschen die eigentlich
nicht demonstrieren
diese gewalt als ungesetzlich empfinden
sich dann in der einen oder anderen form
anschließen alexej nawalny hat den
fehdehandschuh an die kreml mauer
geworfen
ein plan der zumindest am wochenende
aufging
wladimir putin sagen experten muss sich
vorsehen
erstens es gibt eine putin müdigkeit bei
einigen gesellschaften und 2 der kreml
kann heutzutage junge menschen nicht
mehr so indoktrinieren wie früher die
hauptquelle von informationen sind
soziale netzwerke und das internet
und da hat er kenne keinen großen
einfluss
auf der demo treffen wir auch ruslan
wieder aus dem navalny team das das
schicksal seines chefs so viele menschen
berührt freut ihn
er sagt auch dass hier wird sicherlich
ein marathon werden nichts kurzfristiges
wir werden weiter kämpfen müssen für
alexej auch in der zukunft für kommenden
sonntag haben sie bereits zu neuen
protesten aufgerufen